j'imagine que tu ne te rappelle pas ce
que tu faisais le 14 décembre 2015
n'as-tu pas senti quelque chose de
bizarre parce qu à 11h51 exactement
l'espace autour de toi c'est tout d'un
coup dilater le d'un ralenti puis tout
s'est accéléré la pièce autour de toi
s'est contracté et tout est revenu à la
normale ce que tu as expérimenté jour là
le passage d'une onde gravitationnelle
tu l'as compris on va taper dans la
crème le nectar des phénomènes physiques
pourquoi les ondes gravitationnelles ne
sont pas censées exister pourquoi c'est
si dur de les détecter et surtout
pourquoi elle révolutionne autant notre
vision du monde
les ondes gravitationnelles n'aurait
jamais dû exister dans onze
gravitationnelle ya gravitation q c'est
la force qui nous cloue au sol et qui
retient les planètes sur leur orbite
comme tous les concepts scientifiques
l'idée de la gravitation a beaucoup
évolué au cours de l'histoire
pendant longtemps on n'aurait jamais
imaginé que la gravité puisse produire
des ondes
par exemple dès l'antiquité aristote
déclarent plus les objets sont lourds
plus ils tombent but
ah oui tu lâches une boule de pétanque
et une balle de tennis elles n'ont pas
la même vitesse mais plus tard galilée
va montrer que si on enlève tous les
frottements genre l'air tous les objets
tombent à la même vitesse
c'est le principe d'inertie en l'absence
d'air comme sur la lune la gravité fait
tomber plus et marteau à la même vitesse
cependant celui qui va vraiment faire le
lien entre la chute des corps et les
planètes ça sera newton et en observant
tomber des pommes il se dit tiens tiens
pourquoi les objets tombent vers le bas
et pourquoi dans ce cas là la lune ne
nous tombe pas sur la gueule parce que
plus les objets sont lourds et plus ils
mettent une force attractive
non j'ai pas raison oui même toi tu
attires tout sur son passage
c'est une petite force de rien du tout
mais elle est présent dress que dans le
vide spatial de pommes qui n'iront
irrémédiablement pas s'attirer et finir
en orbite l'une de l'autre
par contre la terre est assez grosse
pour générer la gravité nécessaire à
nous retenir à sa surface et c'est comme
ça que notre chien newton explique la
gravité
on peut l'imaginer comme une sorte de
cordes qui retient la terre autour du
soleil et la lune autour de la terre et
ça marche très bien
le problème c'est que tout le monde sait
que cette corde qui relie les planètes
n'existe pas réellement alors de quoi
est composé ce lien invisible
bon ça newton c'est peut-être un génie
mais faut pas trop lui en demander
il évite un peu le problème en supposant
que boire ça doit être une force qui se
propage dans un truc proche du divin
qu'on nommera les nerfs il faudra
attendre deux siècles pour éclaircir ce
mystère début des années 1900 un petit
bonhomme moustachu tranquillement assis
dans un fauteuil s'amuse à appliquer la
géniale méthodes des sciences poser des
questions idiotes ce monsieur moustache
c'est le jeune albert einstein et il est
en train de se demander si un jour on ne
sait pas pourquoi le soleil décidé
soudain de me faire un beau sur le côté
comment la gravité serait perturbé selon
pape sy newton c'est simple le
changement de gravité serait perçue
instantanément dans tout l'univers
peu importe la distance un trou noir qui
naîtrait à 10 milliards d'années lumière
aurait une influence directe sur nous un
film mais direct ça dans la tête
d'einstein
ça colle pas le green intuition
tellement folle que poser dans son
fauteuil il se dit dans sa logique hein
ça peut pas être instantanée puisque
j'ai montré que rien ne va plus vite que
la lumière
du coup pas cette modification de la
gravité peut pas être instantanée obligé
elle doit se propager
il ya un truc qui manque dans la théorie
newton et l' einstein ne va pas
seulement ajouter une petite rustines
pour rafistoler théorie newton il va
complètement bouleverser notre
conception de la gravité de l'espace et
du temps pour lui
espace et temps sont indissociables
quand l'un est modifié l'autre aussi est
plus un objet un espace important plus
il déforme l'espace autour de lui qu'on
peut facilement visualisé en remplaçant
l'espace par un drap ainsi la
trajectoire d'un astéroïde qui passe à
côté de la terre n'est pas modifié parce
qu'il est attiré justement par la terre
à 90 sa trajectoire reste bien une vigne
la sorite va tout droit
ce qui est courbé c'est l'espace dans
lequel ils se déplacent et ça c'est une
[ __ ] de révolution jusqu'à une
cheville
on a longtemps considéré le temps comme
une valeur absolue qui serait la même
art ou du creux de ton lit au fin fond
de l'univers un maître reste partout à m
et toutes les horloges pendule d'autres
fonds tic tac au même rythme fort et
c'est là qu'entre en scène nos fameuses
ondes gravitationnelles dans l'idée
l'espace-temps serait un petit peu comme
une immense piscine quand tu te déplaces
de danse a fait des petites vagues des
sortes d'ondulations qui s'éloignent
progressivement un trou noir qui se
déplacent c'est pareil il va provoquer
des petites vaguelettes de gravité c'est
à dire des ondulations de l'espace temps
c'est pour ça qu'à stein déclare que
tout objet doté d'une masse qui se
déplacent créer des ondes qu'on appelle
ondes gravitationnelles
mais en faisant les calculs on se rend
vite compte que c'est des changements de
gravité de rien du tout pilote
nada même le soleil qui est très lourd
et relativement proche de la terre ne
produit que des bébés dont deux
gravitationnelle minuscule
infinitésimale c'est pour sa canne stein
va vite conclure qu'on ne l'ait
détecterait jamais sauf qu'il est bien
gentil secret albert hockey ces calculs
semble cohérent mais tant qu'on peut
rien observé concrètement en sciences ça
n'a aucune validité et le problème
d'albert c'est que les expériences c'est
pas trop jour des livres le gars j'ai
une théorie de dingue j'ai appelé ça la
relativité générale sauf qu'on pourra
jamais observer nous le prouver mais
dans ma tête ça marche qui qui qui est
avec moi
bien sûr on a observé des trucs qui
laissait sentir qu indirectement il
avait eu du flair genre une déviation
des rayons lumineux lors d'une éclipse
on le décalage de l'orbité de mercure
si bien qu'on s'est résolu à adopter la
théorie de la relativité générale et
c'est concret par exemple sans la
relativité générale les gps se trouve
près d'une dizaine de kilomètres
pourquoi pour deux raisons 1 les
satellites en orbite autour de la terre
sont à très très très haute altitude
ils sont donc
1 un peu moins de gravité terrestre 2
les satellites vont très vite à
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres heure or en relativité
générale
le temps est ralentie pour les objets en
mouvement un pilote d'avion vieillira
plus ou moins vite
seul ou dans quel sens il tourne autour
de la terre à la vitesse d'un satellite
c'est suffisant pour que les gps est un
décalage 30 microsecondes
et c'est beaucoup en ce sens la
relativité générale nos gps ne
marcherait pas mais bon voilà ce n'est
pas une preuve pour l'existence des
ondes gravitationnelles
oui jusqu'au 14 septembre 2015
la naissance des ondes gravitationnelles
cette date va rester dans l'histoire de
la physique
c'est la première fois qu'on a
enregistré une onde gravitationnelle ce
jour-là littéralement la terre à vibrer
ouais on imagine qu on a pris nos trois
dimensions qu'on a tiré dessus comme si
on y tire un tissu peut-être qu'à ce
moment là tu étais dans une pièce tous
les murs se sont écartés comme s'ils ont
gonflé la pièce puis tout est revenu à
la normale et la tuque dixit a eu sa
mi-temps souvient bray et but on a dit
que les ondes gravitationnelles et des
très faibles en fait et c'est vrai mais
ce jour là c'était pas n'importe quel
ondes gravitationnelles tout beau le
soleil
actu une idée d'à quel point ces
abusivement nous ce mastodonte pèse 330
mille fois la masse de la terre
maintenant que tu vois à peu près
combien ça fait plein de soleil tu en
prends 30 tu les prends touche tous les
compresses mais genre tellement fort que
ça rentre dans une petite bille la boule
que tu obtiens va tellement compacte et
dans ce qu'elle va former un [ __ ] de
trou noir
sauf que nous on va pas prendre une
bille mais de beer
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans une
galaxie très lointaine il y a très
longtemps
nos deux trous noirs notre miga
mastodonte infiniment danse et deux
enfants du furet mutuellement leur
attraction est tellement énorme qu'elle
vous tournoyait ensemble à une vitesse
mais complètement folle jusqu'à ce
qu'enfin
là c'est un événement cataclysmique l'un
des plus violents qui puisse exister
dans l'univers en quelques instants
des quantités imaginables d'énergie sont
dégagées l'équivalent de la masse de 3
soleil instantanément volatilisé en
énergie pure ce plus que toute l'énergie
produite en ce moment par toutes les
étoiles de l'univers avec cette image in
l'espace temps est tellement froid c'est
que la perturbation va se propager sur
des années et des années lumière une
onde de choc mais dans le vide
sauf qu'après un trajet 2 milliards
d'années l'ondé tellement aimé que le
déplacement n'excède pas dix millième du
diamètre d'un proto je vais essayer de
te faire sentir à quel point c'est
vraiment genre ont vraiment petit
imagine comprend un grain de sable etc
on l'agrandît jusqu'à ce qu'il fasse la
taille de la terre
à cette échelle quelle place occupe les
atomes du grain de sable chaque atome
aura gonflé pour atteindre la taille
d'un terrain de basket et le noyau à
tony par rapport à ça au centre du
terrain il sera aussi gros qu'un noyau
de cerise mais même à ce niveau de zoom
extrêmes le déplacement créé par l'ong
gravitationnelle reste plus fin que
l'épaisseur d'un cheveu d'un côté la
fusion des trous noirs est si puissante
qu'elle pourrait raser le système
solaire de l'autre on a au final fait
sur la gravité comparable à fait
multicouches comment détecter l'un
détectable le 14 septembre 2015
les scientifiques du monde entier était
prêt depuis cinquante ans plus d'un
millier de physiciens de mathématiciens
d'ingénieurs qui se sont lancés dans cet
incroyable défi car c'est pas facile il
faut se creuser la tête parce que
comment mesure une déformation de
l'espace
si on utilisait une sorte de règle
ultra-précise bas elle subira aussi la
déformation de l'espace
donc on aurait toujours l'impression que
rien ne se passe c'est pour ça qu'ils
vont fuser une constante universelle
un nombre qui est le même partout en
tout point de l'univers se montre
fondamental c'est la vitesse de la
lumière et le type de lumière qu'on va
accuser n'est pas choisi par hasard
il s'agit de la plus puissante et la
plus précise qu'on sache produire un
laser dont la fréquence est réglé au
poil près tellement puissant que tu
pointes sur une bagnole
crabe elle se fait pulvériser même bombe
à l'idée sera de séparer ce faisceau
laser pour le faire passer par deux
chemins différents
deux tubes sous vide spatial de 4 km de
longueur terminée par des miroirs arrivé
au bout le rayon laser sera renvoyé puis
recombiner on appelle ça un
interféromètre si les deux chemins
étaient identiques
pas de problème le signal n'est pas
modifié mais si mignon gravitationnelle
perturbe le détecteur il ya un trajet
dont l'espace temps va être un peu plus
altérée que les autres et le signal au
sort de fait un peu décalé dans ces
conditions quand les deux trajets se
recombinent ils se superposent peut tout
à fait ce qu'on peut observer par une
baisse de l'intensité du signal pendant
un court instant
bon après ça se mesure à quelques
photons sur plusieurs milliards
alors comment être sûr que c'est pas des
micromouvements sismique de la terre ou
même un chercheur qui a été retenu est
d'abord les miroirs sont lisses à
l'atome près et l'ensemble du dispositif
est suspendu pourront éviter les
vibrations sismiques en plus les
chercheurs ont un dernier atout il
existe trois interféromètre
gravitationnelle sur terre s'il détecte
la même anomalie au même moment il ya
des choses non gravitationnelle et c'est
ce qu'on a conclu après des mois de
recherches d'analystes pour être sûr que
c'est vrai toute cette belle aventure a
bien mérité trois prix nobel de physique
et un français qui a eu le prix abel de
mathématiques
rendez vous compte de l' aventure
aristote galilée newton einstein tous
ont tour à tour changer notre idée de la
gravité
pourtant aucun d'eux n'aurait imaginé
toutes les expériences tout le
savoir-faire qu'on a pu mettre en oeuvre
pour réaliser cette expérience
impossible le pire c'est que c'est
maintenant presque banal on détecte des
ondes gravitationnelles quasiment tous
les mois
c'était là tous les jours en nous et on
le voyait pas si vous aimez la science
pensez à vous abonner à notre chaîne
saiosn strache
la vidéo a été écrite par antoine un
passionné qui plus jeune a reçu le
premier prix des olympiades de physique
sur ce sujet autant vous dire qu'on
parle en passionné
merci nous avons suivi ciao
[Musique]